the table gives a position s of a
motorcyclist 40 between zero and three
and cleaning including zero and three
this is just saying that T is T is part
of the interval or T in the interval
between zero and three and we see that
right over here where the distance
traveled s is measured in meters and T
is time in seconds
assume the motorcyclist is accelerating
during the three second period and they
give us the information this is time
between zero seconds and three seconds
and here we have the corresponding
distance that you could use a function
of time the average velocity for T
between one point five and two so T
between one point five and two is 23
meters per second so what they did over
here is they figured out well what is
Delta s over delta T or in this interval
and they figured out that it was 23 23
meters per second and you can verify
that your change in s looks like it's
12.5 your change in time is point or
actually this looks like it so let's see
this is though now this is eleven point
five actually let me see eleven point
five your change in time is 0.5 eleven
point five divided by 0.5 is twenty
three so that's that makes sense and
then they tell us the average velocity
for T between two and two point five
between two and two point five so change
in our distance over change in time they
say is 31 point eight meters per second
and then they say estimate the
instantaneous velocity at T equals two
seconds and use this value to write the
equation of a line tangent to s of T at
the time T equals two so we can try to
approximate we can approximate the slope
of the tangent line right over here
right when T equals two seconds by
taking the average of the slopes of the
tangent lines between one point five and
two and two and two point five so
essentially to approximate the slope of
the tangent line we're going to take the
average of these two rates of change
right over here the
average of these two slopes so let's do
that so the average is going to be 23
plus 31 point 8 over 2 and let's see
what is that equal to that is equal to
54 point 8 over 2 and what is that equal
to let's see 54 divided by 2 is 27 so
it's 27 point for 27 point four so we
can use that as our approximation for
the instantaneous rate of change for the
slope of the tangent line and now we
have to actually put we have to figure
out what that equation actually is they
don't just want the slope so this is the
slope right over here and they say that
they want it in point-slope form
point-slope form and they remind us that
T is the independent variable so when
you're putting something in point-slope
form it really just comes out of the
definition of a line a line always has a
constant slope so let's just imagine
taking let's just imagine taking a a
random point on that line T right this
way T comma capital S a random point on
the line on the tangent line here well
the slope between that and this point is
always going to be constant so what's
the slope between this point and this
point
well what your change in s is going to
be s minus 2 over your change in T which
is T - t - oh sorry your s is s this is
confusing sometimes s minus 30 point 2
over your change in t t minus 2 is equal
to your slope or law anywhere along that
tangent line you're going to have that
slope 27.4 and then you multiply both
sides by t minus 2 and you've put it in
point-slope form so this is the same
thing as s minus 30 point two is equal
to twenty-seven point four times t minus
2